[Musique]
colonne sony larry puis juin il
était le meilleur des amis nous sommes toujours les
meilleurs amis non tu n'es pas qui dit
que nous ne sommes pas assis ailleurs
maintenant si je t'ai fait quelque chose
dis le moi  qu'est-ce que je t'ai fait quand tu
ne m'as rien fait
je ne t'aime plus
tu m'aimais plus hier avec
quoi ne veut-il plus être ami
pourquoi a-t-il 12 ans qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec  tu me [ __ ] de frère c'est donald
siobhan
mais il a toujours été fait
l'autre soir deux heures que tu as passées
à me parler des choses que tu as trouvées
dans ton petit âne secoue papa eh bien
ce n'était pas moi petite merde d'âne c'était
moi la merde de poney qui montre comment  beaucoup
tu écoutais
si tu n'arrêtes pas de me parler
calme et si tu n'arrêtes pas de me déranger
j'ai une paire de ciseaux à la maison et chaque
fois que tu me déranges à partir de ce jour je
prendrai ces ciseaux et je  Je vais enlever un de
mes doigts avec eux et je te donnerai
ce doigt jusqu'à ce qu'il ne me reste plus de
doigts  rendre les choses
plus claires pour vous pas vraiment à partir
de maintenant mais comme vous le savez
[Musique]
ne voudriez-vous pas qu'il ait à faire
un doigt pour voir s'il bluffait
comme non nous ne le ferions pas parce que le pire vient
au pire alors vous  peut toujours jouer du
violon avec quatre doigts je parie que tu
retournes vers ton mauvais gars aucune fête ne
me parle est-ce
que tu ne parles plus à un parent ce
ne serait pas un péché mais le
père non mais c'est  pas très gentil non plus
est-ce
que vous savez de qui nous nous souvenons pour à quel point
ils étaient gentils au 17ème siècle oh
absolument personne ouais nous nous souvenions tous de
la musique à l'époque tout le monde à un homme
connaît le nom de mozart je ne sais pas donc il y
va de cette théorie
[Musique]
Je ne peux plus attendre
cette folie
, appelons-la simplement, nous n'arrêterons pas,
nous l'appelons le début